elles auraient bien voulu s'y arrêter
mais ce sera pour une autre fois je sais
pas encore patiner mais j'aimerais
vraiment apprendre
que ce soit à Montréal Laval ou encore à
Longueuil presque toutes les patinoires
extérieures sont fermées c'est triste
mais on vient de la météo cette année
c'est moins bon l'année passée c'était
génial on va bien voir l'année prochaine
qu'est-ce que ça donne
pour ouvrir une patinoire extérieure à
Montréal il faut une accumulation de 10
cm de neige au sol trois jours
consécutifs avec des températures sous
les moins 5 degrés et aucune
précipitation ne doit tomber pendant ses
journées
les seuls patinoires praticables en ce
moment sont réfrigérés comme celle de
l'Esplanade tranquille dans le Quartier
des spectacles
une des meilleures fun ça fait longtemps
je n'ai pas Disney moi je trouve que
c'est bien de partir dehors dans nos
froid bien profité avec ses amis ses
familles mettre des patinoires
réfrigérées comme celle-là il y en a
qu'une poignée sur lesquelles que 200
patinoires extérieures de la Ville de
Montréal
et on en compte seulement une dans la
valve à Longueuil
il y a beaucoup de personnes qui
aimeraient patiner mais qui n'ont pas
sur la possibilité à cause que disons
les parties noires à côté près d'eux
sont fermés
ici ou quelque part d'autre mais c'est
genre c'est dommage je trouve ça
vraiment plat parce on peut pas passer
du bon temps dehors il faut qu'on soit
dans les arènes que ça coûte de l'argent
en plus
en effet la Reina et la solution de
rechange il faut payer à certains
endroits mais l'accès gratuit ailleurs
comme ici à l'Arena Francis Bouillon
dans shlaga maison neuve et on n'a pas
de neige à l'extérieur parce qu'il y a
beaucoup beaucoup plus de monde que la
normale sur sur les glaces si certains
apprécient l'expérience c'est parfait
des petites lumières température
tempérées on est bien c'est sécuritaire
on est vraiment content en fait on est
chanceux d'avoir ça près de chez nous
parce que justement les sports d'hiver
sont un peu limités à Montréal d'autres
aimeraient mieux patiner à l'extérieur
et je préfère être drôle
CO2 moi non merci c'est pourri on peut
pas jouer ok dehors on peut pas profiter
des vacances on a rien à faire avec les
aveugles on vient ici on a disparu
il faudra encore patienter selon la
ville les conditions météo ne
permettront pas l'ouverture des
patinoires extérieures d'ici la fin de
la semaine